moi
depuis que ce restaurant à et figure sur
les applications de livraison à domicile
le chiffre d'affaires est monté en
flèche ça monte presque 50 % le volume
de commandes est telle que les
propriétaires doivent consacrer un jour
par semaine au moins le dimanche et
enfin le restaurant ben's un pas le
restaurant je veux dire il n'y a pas de
service de table
on fait juste la livraison à la carte
express top menu food aura ce type de
déchets buried ce sont quelques uns des
sites qui sont en train d'envahir le
marché de l'alimentation food aura fait
fureur auprès des jeunes professionnels
qui ne veulent pas cuisiner pour qu'ils
sont trop occupés pour le faire même si
le service est populaire la livraison de
plats provenant de restaurants coûte
cher en premier lieu aux restaurateurs
ouais c'est 30% et prend 1 30% de nom
nos ventes énormes 30%
c'est énorme trente pour cent fois ce ne
sont pas toutes les entreprises qui
exige un pourcentage des recettes mais
lorsque cela se produit les
propriétaires de restaurants n'ont
d'autre choix que de refiler la facture
aux clients certains augmentent les prix
d'autres ajuster l'offre en augmentant
les prix les prix sont pareils mais sauf
qu'il ya tom d un petit changement comme
des fois comme ici l'erié est inclus
mais la livraison les riez pas inclus
parce qu'on est obligé de prendre un
petit montant de ça pour la livraison
il appartient aux consommateurs d'être
vigilents on déplore également les
délais de livraison défend sa propre
danse comme cahier les poissons crus
transformateurs et c'est trop longtemps
leur titre i go le livreur eux
attribuent les retards à la circulation
et au temps requis pour la préparation
des repas ici maxime bertrand radio
canada montréal